you are one of the manliest of men you
really are I say that but I have a
question yes I want to show a picture
that was in a magazine or a newspaper
and we found it today and it's you
carrying a purse yeah yes I think you're
in Monte Carlo the pole you see the
manliness no no I'm that is that's a
purse you're carrying a purse it is
curious when did that become in well
first of all first of all you know what
women have great ideas mm-hmm and they
do and you know what what is funny cuz
I've been married 26 years and I'm with
my wife and I'm always like hey I'll
hold this could you hold this could you
hold that please could you hold this can
you hold this yeah and she's like you're
weighing me down yeah and you know what
i sat there and I said you know what I
need to be independent I need to take a
good idea that is also a great idea put
things into a purse so that no one else
can hold them you can hold them yourself
and you know where everything is let me
tell you something it changed my life I
walk around with my clutch bag
all day and I'm proud of it I'm proud of
you know I have to say and it's all to
avoid because I have found this you
dress up nice you want to go someplace
you put all my wallet the money clip you
know the rabbit's foot
I put the fun glasses sunglasses all
that [ __ ] come yeah in decaying condoms
romantic Oh
I stick that all my pockets and it
doesn't look good it does it you know I
like my stuff form-fitting I'm here can
you tell ya I like everything and then
you have all these lumps I mean where
you gonna put the glasses we're gonna
put the wallet we're gonna put the cell
phone not a cell phone just keep getting
bigger and bigger
yeah uh uh here's a question going to
carry this thing you call it obviously
your murse you call it the murse because
you feel like that's a man's purse but
here's my question would you ever get
one with a strap that went over the
shoulder would you ever do that yeah I
would I would no more to carry let's
call the bet it's called a backpack
that's what they call no no no that's
what this over the back I mean when you
walk around with one that was right here
like a beaut I won't I worry I am I am
confident in my manliness that I could
walk around see it's all of how you look
right if you're walking around like hey
did somebody look like
ah sup man yeah that's what rank you
when you got that look you can do
anything
you have it right on the shoulder yeah
we might as well wear a thong and high
heels cuz you could give you that with
that little you got you gotta put a
little gum in there to it yeah yeah my
high heels hey you know hey thanks for
watching be sure to click subscribe to
see even more great Conan clips you may
now return to your pirated movies and
creepy Japanese pornography